the saudis had had a previous offer from
a man who went to the saudi defense
minister a rich shouty and said i will
raise an army of holy warriors a hundred
thousand strong army and i will kick
saddam out of kuwait city for you and
this man when he found out that they had
allowed american troops and instead of
his offer this man osama bin laden swore
revenge
stephen davis welcome michelle
thank you very much pleased to be here
how long have you been researching
british airways flight 149
half my life uh i first
um
got a tip off about this when i was on
the news desk of the independent on
sunday
in august 1990 three days after the
plane landed
um and i'm
64 years
old now so
31 years so pretty much half my life
it's been a long long journey what's
compelling about this story why have you
bothered spending three decades on it
i'm an investigative reporter first off
i don't like being lied to
um
and
but several things drove me on
these people
suffered a double injustice
first off they were landed in a war zone
um as a result of a secret mission
ordered by mrs thatcher
but secondly they were denied even the
recognition
of the terrible things that happened to
them
when they were in captivity so a few
months
after this the royal military police
were commissioned by the government to
do a load of interviews with the human
shields as they had become known
and uh they produced a report called
operation sandcastle
and
um it was a horror story
of rapes
other assaults mock executions near
starvation conditions it was supposed to
be presented to parliament and they
probably suppressed it and it has been
kept secret for 30 years
so the people on the plane
were lied to about why they
were there in the first place
but also denied recognition of the
terrible things that happened to them
while they were there
so those two things drove me on the more
i met
weird official denials and contradictory
denials from british airways and the
british government the more i kept going
and then the other thing was meeting
the victims of this
many of whom have suffered
ptsd and lifelong trauma as a result of
this ordeal and again
just denied the public recognition so
every time i would talk to one and at
one stage during every interview you
could see them start to tremble or tear
up as they remembered something terrible
that had happened to them
it made me angrier and more determined
to carry on
okay so someone that's not familiar with
this particular case what's the story
okay
so on the morning of the 1st of august
uh in 1990
uh saddam had been threatening to invade
kuwait for some time a huge amount of
iraqi troops were gathered on the border
it was reported by the bbc that morning
a british airways flight 149
was due to take off and fly to kuwait
which was a crew transfer and refueling
stop
and then on to madras in india
and then on to kuala lumpur
as it sat on the ground
there was a
two-hour delay
during this time
a group of young very fit men
got on board at the last minute
uh most of the passengers thought
instantly these guys are soldiers
went to the back of the plane sat down
the plane took off
when it was um
between three and four hours flying time
from kuwait
the invasion started
iraqi troops crossed the border
all other flights that were going to
kuwait city were turned away
but ba149 was not
and it flew on
it landed in um
kuwait at four o'clock on the morning of
the second
and at that stage
iraqi tanks were already in the city and
surrounding the airport
when the
door opened and clitherthy the chief
person
there was a uniform british military
officer waiting and clyde thought he
must be here for the kuwaiti royal who
was traveling in first class
but no this man was there to collect the
young men at the back he said can you
please get them and we're in a hurry
so these men get off
they have people waiting for them with
cases and gear
and then they vanish from the airport
never to be seen again not captured by
the iraqis
everybody else on the plane
is captured by the iraqis
and used as human shields
and so who that mystery group were
and why they were
there and why the plane was allowed to
land
in the midst of a war zone were the
three things that drove my investigation
over the years
is it likely that the only reason the
plane was delayed in taking off to
permit those guys to make it on
that appears to be the case uh when i
interviewed captain brunit who was the
captain
who subsequently turns out to have been
an mi6 asset he told me it was an issue
with the air conditioning
it may or may not have been but it was
seemed like a bit of an excuse we know
now
that the men who arrived at the last
minute
were checked in using military ticketing
codes
and the british airways lady who checked
them in
who subsequently told colleagues that
they had military codes
subsequently refused to talk about it
and remarkably enough
chris
i was given a new job at
the ministry of defense
i've seen that captain
say the air conditioning thing on a
documentary as
well yeah i mean look it may have been i
i think it was one of the the captain
always has the
ability to delay the fight if he's
worried about it richard told me richard
brunit told me that he was also thought
if he delayed the flight
um maybe it would be cancelled yeah yeah
if you push it later yeah the ground
invasion may begin and they won't
actually have to take off
yes but to be honest as i subsequently
found during the course of the my
investigation some of the things he told
me you know two initial interviews were
let's say
a bit deceptive was there anyone else
interesting on the passenger manifest
yeah there was a um there was a kuwaiti
royal a senior member of the royal
family who was seen to have double duty
as both um
the minister of sport and the head of
security
and um he was on the flight
and he died uh shortly so he went to the
desmond palace and he actually died
i think defending the palace from iraqis
so
he was one of the early casualties
okay other than that the they were a
mixture of
um there were a few people landing in
kuwait
there was an american banker called
george shalom and his family who had a
remarkable story um of course the crew
were getting off in kuwait and there was
a replacement crew to fly on the next
leg
but most of the passengers british
french
malaysian canadian
um
indian
germans spanish
et cetera et cetera 15 different
countries danish we're flying on to
either
madras or um kuala lumpur and
some of these people made decisions
which seemed in the hindsight to be okay
which really proved out to be costly a
couple called the hulk yards kiwis
fellow kiwis of mine uh henry and daphne
halcyard
who had were new zealanders but also had
british passports
made the last minute decision to fly on
their british passports
which meant in captivity they were
treated as brits not new zealanders
and that was not a good deal for them
what happens once the passengers are
captured by the iraqis
well this was the interesting thing um
it was clear originally the iraqis
didn't really know what to do with them
the initial few days chris of the
occupation were chaotic
very chaotic
and
actually some people just escaped then
by getting in their cars and driving to
saudi arabia and jordan
a lot of the troops that were initially
occupying kuwait were conscripts
into saddam's army not the republican
guard who were the elite the fanatics
and the conscripts were by all accounts
pretty hopeless and not to mention
apparently uh scruffy uniforms and not
very well fed they were the conscripts
were often hungry
anyway
so
the iraqis
were had this prize a british airways
plane and all of these people
didn't really know what to do with them
so they took them to hotels
and they kept them in these hotels for
several days or sometimes a week
and that was an interesting example then
of
of spin
kind of affecting how people think of a
story
so initially
the foreign office is briefing yes 149's
landed in a war zone
but don't worry
the passengers are like having a little
holiday they're um they're sipping
cocktails by the pool and the sunshine
in luxury hotels
and um
and of course with spin
often the first version of the store you
get out
is what is believed um so that became
the common belief
and it was true for a few days
as i said the iraqis kept them in hotels
and they were looked after by the air
crew and they were fed and
and but then of course saddam worked out
that he had this prize
and after that
they were sent
and often moved constantly
and ended up at 70 different places
all over kuwait and
iraq along with
westerners captured on the ground
who became human shields who joined them
and these 70 places were sites which
saddam had identified as potential sites
which the allies would attack
if they attacked his country or tried to
kick him out of
iraq so that's where the phrase human
shields goes
saddam
put them there in dams and chemical
warfare plants and ironically enough
this was when saddam actually had
weapons of mass destruction programs
and so he put them in places he thought
the allies would bomb
so for a long time of course these
people thought there would be a good
chance they would be killed by their own
side
and then they had hellish a hellish time
in captivity most of them
what is this team of operatives doing
while everyone's in this first hotel
okay so uh they dispersed one uh group
were actually picked up by iraqis uh but
obviously not a very clever bunch and
talked their way out of it
and were let go how many was there in
total of these specials
the uh
nine four two men teams and an
intelligence officer
um
so this is a surveillance operation it's
important to bear in mind
people have this idea of
special forces operations as men who
go in with guns blazing and all firing
sas sbs all of that and of course they
can do if required
if they're attacking somebody but the
specialization of these groups
is actually to
um to hide and observe and report back
intelligence to blend in
um and so these teams were set up in
various parts of kuwait
to report on what the iraqi movements
were the placement of where the
republican guard was
you know where they were putting their
artillery classic intelligence which you
then feed back to london and washington
so they had all gone and the passengers
were all in captivity
how do you know what these intelligence
officers were doing surely this is all
secret information well it was and um
for a long time and then uh i've done a
lot of um reporting on special forces
and um
i have by the way on three
no four separate occasions had the uk
government take legal action against me
to stop stories coming out
and um i've i've beaten them four times
in a row so i'm probably a bit of an
irritant
so i have a lot of contacts
and eventually
with a colleague from television new
zealand we flew to britain and it's the
usual thing you have a contact who
trusts you and then he introduced you to
somebody else and
eventually i had a man um who's very
well known in the special forces
community and has
been on um television called snap award
and he confirmed that the mission took
place because one of his mates was on it
and then after a long other process i
actually ended up interviewing people
from the mission and who planned the
mission so this is all from the horse's
mouth
okay so what are they doing there
there's four of them get
caught but then let go because they talk
their way out of it what are the two of
them get caught but and so the four two
men teams are at four different places
in kuwait
my contacts ended up in southern kuwait
which was one of the crucial things so
their job
uh they ended up
setting up a hide
in a in a village
near a crossroads where they could
observe the movement of iraqi troops
and they would hide all day long
and um
they were quickly able to establish that
the iraqis were taking up defensive not
offensive positions in southern kuwait
and not getting too near the border with
saudi arabia
this particular group
two guys
got into trouble
because
they ate some rations which made one of
them really really ill
with severe food poisoning
and so well
that they had to be rescued
and they ended up
with one guy dragging his mate across
the desert
hour after hour
to this wadi
where they were rescued by a american
special forces helicopter
and taken to a war u.s warship called
the us antietam
where they ended up in the sick bay
now this is an interesting thing chris
this was a key moment for me in
confirming part of the investigation
i ended up with many sources the british
government will tell you now
if you phone them up tomorrow
they would say oh no this never happened
chris
this this mission never existed
these people it just didn't happen
but unfortunately for them
i tracked down
the captain of the u.s warship the
antietam
a wonderful man called lawrence
eddingfield he's a pastor now isn't he
yes so he had gone from being a captain
to being a very senior planning man at
the pentagon
and then a vicar at a church in san
diego where i went to talk to him
so a man of completely and utterly
unimpeachable reputation
and unfortunately for the brits
um lawrence decided to tell the truth
and confirmed
every single part
of the story
he visited the men in the sick bay he
knows exactly what happened he had them
on his ship
they were picked up by this rescue
helicopter that arrived on 149.
so we're in this weird business now
sometimes i mean look i'm i i i'm not a
person who is opposed to national
security on legitimate grounds
clearly
special forces and spying there has to
be a degree of secrecy
and a lot of my contacts you know would
would say ultimately that's the case but
sometimes it becomes absurd you know 30
years later they're still denying it
when i have an on-camera confirmation
from
the the
us captain so yeah it becomes a bit
crazy really what are the conditions of
the passengers at this point
okay so
it was luck of the door
so first off
um
how you were treated
depended on whether your country was
being
seen to be aggressive and conte intent
towards saddam or not
um and i had a memorable occasion
uh conversation recently with one of the
stewardesses so she described
being in the hotel
and iraqi troops came in and they had
two lists
and it's and then they got all the
passengers and they divided you on the
left you on the right
which of course has a lot of sinister
historical echoes especially with some
german people on board yeah
absolutely
and this
but this woman said so she realized that
the people on the left
uh
were mainly white and americans and
british and so forth
and the people on the other side
were
indians and malays and others
but the funny thing not amusing in
retrospect but she thought to herself
she looked at the other group and
thought oh those poor people
they're going to be really given a hard
time and we're all right because we're
on this side and in fact it was the
exact opposite of course
uh the indians and malays were better
treated and and let go
early
so saddam had you know this
this sort of as it were um i don't know
whether i can say it on your podcast
[ __ ] list effectively
and
um
and then the french
for a long time a lot of french
passengers captured over 50.
for a long time they thought
that they were going to be okay because
mitterrand
was refusing to join
bush's grand coalition
and then suddenly one day there's an
announcement that mitterwander the
french have joined and they're suddenly
plummeting to despair
because that puts them in the bad
category not the good category
right from the start of course the
british and americans were prizes
because thatcher was gung-ho and saying
yeah we're going to kick them out we're
going to invade bush was saying i've
drawn a line in the sand his famous
quote
but other countries
people who had irish passports
were okay so it was a real mixture in in
terms of nationality
and
of course
the iraqis also reacted to every single
thing that bush and thatcher said
so at one stage the passengers heard to
their horror somebody asked that your
question saying
[Music]
are the fact that all these human
shields being being held in iraq and
kuwait
will it stop you taking military action
and thatcher said oh no we won't and so
saw the passenger all thinking well
that's great we're going to be bombed
that's just terrific and at that very
moment by the way in one of the camps
in a couple of the camps iraqi troops
turned up and started digging big
trenches
and eventually the passengers were told
by some friendly guards over very sorry
but when the invasion starts
where to shoot you
and dump you in these dump your bodies
in these trenches
so how you were treated first off was um
dictated by geopolitics
and the other part was really the lack
of the draw in who held you who was in
charge of your captivity
so if you were in a camp run by the
bathursts
who were the real hardliners
real hardliners
you got a very hard time indeed and one
of the most shocking stories i heard was
some people in a camp who were taken out
of the camp in the middle of the night
driven out in the desert
made to get out
given shovels
made to dig a deep trench
made to kneel in front of the trench
soldiers lined up behind them and of
course
by this stage the people are convinced
they're going to be shot in the back of
the head and dumped in the trench
and then um
there's a click
and the and the bathurst fall about
laughing it was their idea of a joke
psychological torture
so you could end up in a place like that
a couple of the people i interviewed
such as barry manners
ended up with a
an engineer at a dam
who was determined to treat them
courteously despite saddam's
instructions
and despite the guards wanting to be
meaner
so he took a great risk i mean he
actually invited them to tea at his
house and did what he could tried to
give them food
bowie became lifelong friends with this
man which is rather nice
and um and and mr troll as i call him
immigrated to sydney where i spoke to
him recently so there was an element of
randomness there was an element of lack
of the draw
um
a lot of people thought about escaping
and there were various complicated
escape plans
there was a bit of the old pow spirit
among the brits you know
they didn't quite get to the stage of
working out how to dig a tunnel but it
was more or less like that but when they
heard that
uh douglas cosgry
who was a brett who had decided to try
and drive out
ended up being his car was riddled with
gunfire by iraqis and he was killed
that kind of put a damper on was he one
of the passengers
no he was captured on the ground
but my book operation trojan horse of
course includes the stories of all the
human shields both the ones who arrived
on 149 and the ones who were captured on
the ground but that that was quickly
communicated
to everybody and after that it was they
had to be pretty careful a lot of the
iraqi guards
were pretty trigger-happy
they would pull their weapon
[Music]
you know
um at one stage um
bowie manners told me he lost his tempo
and
started shouting at the guy he just had
enough he started shouting at the guards
and the officer just got it pointed at
bowie and was going to shoot him till
other people calmed him down
so it was a very
it was a terrible ordeal and as i said
what really has made me cross over the
years is
hopefully it's changed in the last week
or so
but people didn't realize what a
horrible time these people had and some
people used to say to them oh
when they got back oh well you're safe
and well you had a bit of a holiday you
know
terrible
there's a um one passenger who was 14
years old and jennifer chapel
and she has suffered lifelong
depression and mental health problems
she's literally never recovered from her
ordeal
as of others
didn't the captain try and hide
somewhere the captain and some of the
crew
yeah so this is a controversial moment
so
at one stage um
bournier
decided to escape
and he did so
and he took a few of his crew with him
not all
and it's fair to say
i wouldn't judge the man not having
walked in his shoes in that difficult
circumstance
um but it's fair to say that a lot of
the passengers
felt completely abandoned
you know the captain deserting the
sinking ship
and i had a very interesting
conversation with uh richard burnied
about this when i was interviewing him
so he ended up he escaped and ended up
with the kuwaiti resistance
and i asked him i said
richard how did you find
the kuwaiti resistance after you escaped
and he said well
i walked out of the hotel in my shorts
and t-shirt
and i knocked on a few doors
and i found them
and i was sitting in his living room at
the time and there are certain moments
as a journalist when you're looking at
somebody
and
you know they're not
telling the truth
and he was looking at me and he knew i
knew he wasn't telling the truth
but clearly he wasn't going to say
anything more
the idea of this uh englishman
knocking on doors in an iraqi occupied
city saying hello is anybody from the
kuwaiti resistance here is that's the
most british way to do it though if
you're going to whatever it is it is me
is this the kiwi resistance i'm looking
for you at the moment
but it's absurd and the kawaii kuwaiti
resistance was subject to the most
brutal repression and when i read
richard's diary actually one of the
resistance people helping him um
was brutally captured and tortured
one of the great uns told stories about
this by the way is the incredible
heroism of the creating resistance many
of them young women
so richard's escaped in fairness to him
also he had
obviously as an mi6 asset he had reason
to be worried about being captured and
he also had a reason to be worried about
being captured funnily enough because of
his dad
so at one stage the burniats lived in
baghdad
and his dad was a businessman
who apparently had fallen out with
saddam hussein
so saddam hussein is not somebody you
want to make an enemy of
so you know there's a lot of different
opinions
on
whether richard burnett was
right to free flee
he clearly had been given
contacts and the resistance in advance
to use if he had to and that's how he
found them
but you know i wouldn't judge i mean you
know
genuine fear of his life probably
should he have gone should he say who
knows and richard by the way like
so many of these people who were
involved in this by the way chris
died before their time
you know
richard died in his 50s his co-pilot
gordon gold died in his 50s the chief
engineer wildman died in his 60s so
that's three for three in the cockpit
who died what circumstances
well a variety um i think a heart attack
cancer you know i'm not saying anything
nefarious happened to them but you know
definitely the
the accumulated stress and things of
that ordeal lots of people carol miles
the woman who checked in the men
and
kept the secret
she died before her time
mike london the controller at ba on the
day a man who i would have loved to have
interviewed died of a heart attack just
a few months later
many of the passengers who've suffered
mental health problems or physical
health problems have died
early
stress is a hell of a drug
exactly poor um
denise dyer one of the stewardesses her
husband neil
who who suffered badly from ptsd and who
spent a long time
trying to get to the truth of this
matter
died british airways by the way tweeted
this
their own staff
and passengers
appallingly
i mean
they
when several passengers several of the
staff tried to
write books or find out the truth
british airways threatened them
and it's passengers you know here's a
situation where british airways fought
tooth and nail
all the way to the house of lords
not to pay compensation to the british
passengers
at the same time it turns out
they got a massive insurance settlement
from their plane
now their plane
was not destroyed by the iraqis as we've
been told for years it was sitting
intact on the runway it was destroyed by
the u.s air force
deliberately
so here's british airways denying any
compensation to its passengers while
pocketing a large check because you know
the allies
blew up their own plane amazing you knew
this right because there's this very
famous photo the back of a blown-off
tale of of the british airways flight
but as you said in the book
the iraqis were taking light bulbs out
copper piping anything that they could
that was a value because they had quite
scarce resources so having an entire
functioning plane and then blowing that
up was at odds with their modus operandi
outside of that so
it looks like the americans blew up the
british plane
too and the request of the brits almost
certainly i mean it always struck me as
being unlikely remember that
it couldn't have been accidental i mean
remember ba149 was literally sitting
there by itself at the airport it's not
like it's
next to a military target or surrounded
by other things it's sitting there on
its own
and
for weeks and weeks and weeks
and i said the iraqis were busy looting
stuff and and and why not the plane's a
prize
why not just fly it back alternatively
um just leave it there
yeah exactly um as a symbol and suddenly
it ends up as this wreckage
and as i said it really always struck me
as unlikely that it happened and then i
had two different sources one in the u.s
and one britain confirmed that
it was blown up by our lot as it were
how did the passengers
get back because they're distributed
right you've got 70 different locations
you've got some of them in hiding with
the kuwaiti resistance
what what happens to get them back to
the country
well a lot of different things really
um first off there would there were some
early releases of various nationalities
who saddam thought
should be on his side
um you know malaysians and indians and
others got home reasonably early
um
then um
a lot of
the the passengers used to call them the
human shells used to call them celebrity
visits
people get turning up in baghdad
to be
uh captured on camera talking to saddam
hussein
negotiating the release of hostages
um
jesse jackson turned up um
i think edward heath went
tony ben who were these people
um uh jesse jackson's the
american um
well-known um african-american
politician
um and civil rights campaigner and um
heath of course is former british prime
minister ben's a british politician
anyway the celebrity visits they
they turned up
and there was this great photo
opportunities and
um and then saddam would release a few
people so they could go home
um
the passengers were very cynical about
this exercise as they were about the
iraqis used to run this
television program called guest news and
the passengers would be gathered
and saddam would turn up with an iraqi
crew
and
hear that all these happy people the
benefit of our wonderful hospitality
that's when the famous image happened of
uh saddam patting the boy stuart
lockwood on the end
um so
and by the way during this unreported
saddam uh
a few minutes later or beforehand
another little boy
um apparently kicked him in the shins
hard
and saddam turned round and said who are
his parents that would have been a bad
moment for the parents
so anyway there was all this weird stuff
going on like um
and people being released then after a
month or so he announced he would let
the woman and children go he was being
at the time i think he had hopes that
they would let him keep kuwait and there
would be some negotiating settlement so
this was the sort of great dictator's
gesture
and that led to some incredibly intense
moments
because um husbands and wives
you know
does the wife go
and the husband stay
the husband of course had no choice but
the wife had a choice
and
i had one amazing description in the
camp where a lot of couples were kept
there was this
long
after they heard there was this kind of
long night
of intense emotional whispering
conversations
um
where husbands and wives decided
and then incredibly painful departures
some of the wives decided to stay with
their husbands
no
the health yards
daphne and henry
um
daphne decided to
stay with henry
and when i interviewed them and this is
interviewed them on camera seven years
later
when
they talked about the moment
just the memory of it
daphne had tears in her eyes
and henry
was very emotional and said look i will
forever be grateful to her
for staying
with me
um but of course
i think he also
constantly had doubts about whether it
was the right thing to do as you would a
natural human
was this the right thing to do and henry
by the way
his daughter rowan said he never ever
recovered
from this ever
um
and he died a few years later daphne
died recently
um
so yeah these tremendously intense and
emotional
decisions
so that happened then of course saddam
had a whole package
of me and and a few women
and often by the way chris they were
moved around so some of them
they were shuffled around in the middle
of the night
not knowing where they were going
and they'd be at an electricity
substation so they recognized sometimes
they didn't even know where they were
because they were shoved in at night in
in sheds and the windows were
so they could they could have been
anywhere another time
they the bus turned up at something
which was obviously to do with chemical
warfare so that was particularly scary
for them they were only
a few you know imagine that being bombed
i mean just absolutely horrendous they
had to live with that
um
the quality of the food deteriorated the
attitude of the guards deteriorated
um it was clear they were going to be
killed if there was an invasion
so for several months after that it was
even more hallish
for those who were caught behind
then
saddam hussein of course in many ways
was a very
odd individual in his
decision making as we know
um
for instance why would anybody
pretend to the west
he still had weapons of mass destruction
programs when he didn't
which you know if he'd owned up to it
and allowed them to inspect it it would
be no 2003 gulf
war but also
in a decision which nobody to this day
ever understands
in december
as the war build up was in full
swing and the westerners were seriously
worried the western military planners
were seriously worried about these
hostages
they had the sas and delta force had
drawn up possible rescue plans
put in special forces teams and and try
to get them out before the war started
so there's no boots on the ground yet at
this stage no no it's a build up to war
um
and
but they decided it was impossibility
they didn't really know where everybody
was and this would have been 70 odd
simultaneous special forces rescue
operations
so
they had to abandon it so western
planners
military planners
their planning was really made difficult
by the presence of these human shields
which was saddam's intention
should we bomb this dam should we bomb
this other place
uh here's a place we probably should
bomb a bridge but we don't know whether
the human human shields are there or not
they had some locations identified and
others not
um
if the marines storm
into this beach at kuwait
should we first shell these
hotels and gun emplacements
maybe not because there are hostages in
that hotel
so all these incredibly difficult
decisions
and saddam had
a trump card to play
now thatcher and bush kept saying it
didn't matter
but it mattered to the military planners
and
there is quite a history chris of
prisoners of war being killed in in in
bombing missions
uh famously years later it was revealed
in hiroshima and nagasaki
hundreds and hundreds of americans were
killed they were held as prisoners in
the cities
um
so here's the situation
and then in early december
before the war started
saddam
i don't know
woke up one day
and made a public announcement
that he was letting everybody go
and the military planners were overjoyed
this removed a whole set of problems
that they then didn't have to think
about
nobody knows why
as i said the best explanation i've
heard
is that still in the back of his mind he
thought he could negotiate his way out
of the war
the war started by the way in a dispute
about an oil field which is half in
kuwait and half in iraq the proceeds of
the oil field that was one of the main
issues
so the best explanation for this
inexplicable decision
was he thought i'll make another gesture
i'll have the world on my side i'm a man
of peace
excuse me
i'm a man of peace
and um
and this will help me as a negotiator
but whatever the reason was
all the men got let go
wartime there were these tremendously
emotional reunions
but then everybody forgot about them
it's classically the media where we
you know often it for big stories we can
only concentrate on one big thing at a
time and i maybe even at the independent
on sunday i was really interested in
investigating these people but by
december the war was coming
and the invasion was coming the gulf war
was coming
desert storm was coming
so
we all
got interested in that
and and you know we set up a war desk
and we went for coverage and
correspondence and tv crews went and
and so the hostages were forgotten
and left they got virtually no help of
any kind
no office of
psychological help
no real offers of financial help
there was a british medical journal
study saying there was an extraordinary
uh high percentage of them that lost
their jobs their homes their
their
mental well-being
they were forgotten about
um they were briefly debriefed when they
arrived by spies who wanted to know
where they were and what the place
looked like
and that was it they were gone
and then as i said a few months later
operation sandcastle is commissioned
which would have
been presented to parliament and
reminded people what happened to the
hostages
but was suppressed clearly because the
war was over betrayed as a great success
victory for bush victory for thatcher
you know victory for freedom in the west
um
and they didn't want anybody thinking of
or being reminded of why british airways
flight 149 landed
and what actually happened to all the
human shields in captivity
what was thatch's reason for british
airways flight landing
to um was basically a favor to the
americans to get an observation team on
the ground in a hurry
um so they could keep an eye on the
kuwaiti
um sorry the iraqi troop movements in
kuwait what was her public what was her
public statement about it though what
was the justification she can't have
said that to the public
no no no she's denied it it happened and
and she gave a completely false
not denied the plane landed but she's
denied that it ever happened there was a
mission she gave a completely face false
statement to parliament a month later
uh she said
the plane landed
um
the crew got off the replacement crew
got on and all of this happened before
the invasion then she repeated it all of
this happened before the invasion it's
completely untrue the invasion started
when the plane was four hours flying
time and she knew on the day i have the
actual intelligence flash messages
which went around in london and
washington
so a month later she's lying about it
and then the lies and cover-ups have
been
perpetrated
ever since it's fair to say the the
people i've talked to from the team on
the ground
felt it was a military success
that they delivered valuable
intelligence on the iraqi troop
movements and they helped
um but they have a conscience about
what happened to the passengers
you see one of the things you know often
things in history chris as we know are
cock-ups and not conspiracies
um to an extent and it's important to
understand when they originally drew up
this plan
the team who were going in
were told
that the
um
[Music]
kuwaiti military would hold out
for between three and five days
when the iraqis cross the border
as i explained in operation trojan horse
the kuwaiti military collapse like a
pack of cards in a few hours
the kuwaiti royal family
took off to saudi arabia in a long
convoy of mercedes and road range rovers
without leaving any instructions for the
defense of their country
so rather than uh
three to five days iraqi tanks arrived
at kuwait airport in about three and
four hours
and so it's fair to say that the mission
as originally planned 149 would have
taken off
long before
but that doesn't let them off the hook
because the simple fact is
that the invasion started when the plane
was four hours flying time and could
have been turned around
any time up to the point of final
descent by which days iraqi troops were
at the airport and kuwaiti air traffic
controllers remember
kwadi air traffic controllers were
contacting a kuwaiti airlines flight and
say you must land in bahrain
don't come here
and yet nobody told 149 not to land so
outrageous it was a case of the air
traffic controllers not telling 149 not
to land not that they told them and the
captain
didn't hear or turned off the radio
they didn't well this they the air
traffic controllers never delivered a
warning
all all messages on approach were normal
messages now here's one mystery by the
way and if there's anybody out there who
knows this please feel free to contact
me one mystery i've never been able to
solve
is why kuwaiti air traffic controllers
who had
radar with all the approaching planes or
flights
why would they say turn away
to one plane
and not another i mean they're
responsible professionals doing their
job
why would they do that the best
explanation that i've heard
and i haven't had it thoroughly sourced
enough to put it in the book but i
didn't so i didn't
but it's plausible
was that the brits because there was a
big british military liaison team in
kuwait the brits had put somebody in the
control tower
effectively taking it over
to make sure no kuwaiti air traffic
control is said to 149 oh you better
turn around here because they wanted the
plane to land and all of this was to
facilitate getting those nine men
absolutely under the ground getting the
team onto the ground who disappeared and
and and while
um
others were captured and so
if there's anybody out there who was
knows what happened in the air traffic
control tower please uh feel free to
to um
contact me so the the
as a military mission i think
you know you can say there was
justification for it but there was no
justification once you knew the invasion
started
of risking those people's lives and bear
in mind chris that in landing the plane
while tanks were at the airport and the
airport soon to be bombed by mig
fighters
of course they were dropping their own
team in it as well it was perfectly
possible that those nine guys could have
been captured
and i can tell you what if their
identities had been revealed as special
forces they would have been very badly
treated indeed
by
the iraqis
what's the broader geopolitical
implications of what's happened
so this is interesting um
the team was sending back very clear
intelligent the fear was
that saddam having taken over kuwait
would go on to invade northern iraq
at which point the dictator would
control
40 percent of the world's oil supply
so i have historically as it were i've
read all the history and all the reports
we have this moment when uh dick cheney
and norman schwarzkopf fly to saudi
arabia i think the 6th of august it was
four days after the plane landed
and they talk to the saudi king
[Music]
and they show him satellite images
and
they say look we can help you
stop the iraqis invading your country
but you have to allow our troops and
planes to base
themselves in your country
now during this famous meeting
the king turned to his fellow princes
and brothers
who universally said no
don't want it
and
[Music]
the saudis had by this stage sent their
own scout troops over the border
and could detect no sign of iraqi troops
close to the border
and
by this stage
the teams who had landed on 149
were sending intelligence back
saying
there's no evidence they're adopting
offensive positions
and it turns out there was satellite
imagery taken by the russians but
apparently quite accurate
and broken by an american newspaper at
the time although the story was ignored
that the iraqi troops weren't in the
offensive positions
so they had all of this suggesting
that there was no need for american
troops on saudi soil
and the kings everybody telling the king
don't do it
but chaney and schwarzkopf saying oh
you might be invaded by the iraqis we
can help you let our troops in so for
some reason the king
said yes they were so surprised by the
way that schwarzkopf said
he nearly fell off his chair
and dick clark who was in the meeting a
senior state department guy said we were
shocked we never expect them in a
million years to say yes
so
the saudis had had a previous offer
from a man who went to the saudi defense
minister
a witch shouty and said i will raise an
army of holy warriors
a hundred thousand strong army
and i will kick saddam out of kuwait
city for you
and this man when he found out that they
had allowed american troops
and instead of his offer
this man osama bin laden
swore revenge
and of course on 911 carried out his
threat
there would have been no 911
without
american troops on saudi soil
and dick clark
in the book trojan horse you will find a
remarkable comment from dick clark
who's an expert in this field
saying
actually 30 years of chaos and
destruction in the middle east
including the gulf war including isis
including failed states
all comes from that crucial decision
to have american troops on saudi soil
so the significance of this
is immense
much wider than just
the hostages and curiously
this is one of the unexamined parts of
history
people just accepted at face value
that cheyney and schwarzkopf were
presenting a proper case
and presenting the accurate intelligence
as we know now of course there's a long
history of misuse of intelligence in
these areas
um but this is huge this is a mat this
is this is where history changed gears
and my closing sentence in um
operation trojan horse is
if the if the secret team that had gone
in on 149 if their intelligence had been
acted upon
and
there'd be no american troops allowed
and the world would clearly be a safer
more peaceful place
now
clearly
do you think that
cheney and schwarzkopf were lying about
what the british intelligence officers
were feeding back were they
uh a culpable insight
on the ground that was allowing them to
say we've actually seen it british have
got some intelligence offices that are
down there this is what we're being told
that's a good question i mean they had
satellite pictures which apparently
showed iraqi troops somewhere
although there doesn't seem to be
satellite pictures which showed them
near the border
they could have i i think it was a case
of cherry picking that's the problem
with misuse of intelligence of course
intelligence by definition it's not this
there's not exactitudes and intelligence
it's
bits of this and bits of that and best
guesses and you can often have
intelligence that's contradictory
so you can just cherry pick the bits
that you want
to achieve the aim that you want
and and ignore the rest
um although that being said cheney of
course has a reputation for um for uh
you know completely exaggerating and
totally misusing intelligence so yeah
like if you're going to lie about what
the assets are feeding back to you in
terms of information why not just lie
about the assets being there at all
and of course part of the interesting
thing in the cover-up
you know say the year after the gulf war
when america had bases in saudi and
you know maybe some of the consequences
becoming clear to people
if there was a revelation
that the brits were delivering
intelligence on the ground right from
the start
that the iraqis were adopting defensive
positions there would have been very
hard questions asked by everybody so
that was kind of another reason for the
cover-up i think
you know the fact the mission was there
the fact they dropped all these people
in terrible circumstances and the fact
they ignored a lot of the intelligence
that was delivered
and
bear in mind that right from the start
um
mrs thatcher was very gung-ho about this
whole thing
right from the first minute
one of the extraordinary revelations i
think in my in my book in operation
trojan horse was when the team were
briefed
they were told that if necessary
if necessary
and if the republican guard were in
southern kuwait looking um threatening
uh thatcher was prepared to authorize a
tactical nuclear weapon
on the republican guard
so basically thatcher was prepared to
nuke southern kuwait which is just
mind-boggling really
when i when we spoke to her private
secretary he denied it all but you know
my team my people are
adamant and actually if you look at
thatcher's comments about the use of
nuclear weapons there's a long history
of her being willing to use them
dating right back to the falklands
so
yes um so there were multiple reasons
including i think
protecting thatcher's reputation you
know i think this was part of the
cover-up
the fact that she was all kind of you
know
super gung-ho and
super aggressive i think there was an
element of protecting her reputation as
a statesman and of course as you said
previously during this whole business
she was actually dumped and replaced by
john major
yeah perilous time
to be a prime minister in the uk at that
point
what what about the last
few months or so because obviously
you've it's 30th anniversary
you've brought the book out
calling to account people trying to say
british airways what have you done why
haven't we seen the correct reports look
at all of the damage that's been done to
people look at the implications that
occurred geopolitically in terms of
terror in terms of boots on the ground
and wars and loss of life and all that
stuff what's happened recently
okay so
um
for a long time i never thought i was
actually going to get the book out
uh
the previous efforts had been frustrated
actively frustrated i'd been
deliberately sent misinformation and
disinformation to disrupt the process
years ago
and and unfortunately most of the media
had given up on this so for the last 15
years i've carried out my investigation
in my own time
um
the
fantastic new statesman and it's great
editor and friend of mine peter wilby
ran a piece by me about
16 years ago about this but most of the
media had given up put it in the too
hard basket so i
kept going
and got a publisher and an american
publisher
and we arranged this reunion
on august the 2nd which it was supposed
to be a 30-year reunion but the pandemic
put paid to that
so it was august the second just gone
and
um
so
i appeared at a press conference
alongside me remarkably
was an emma a retired mi6 officer called
tony pace
who courageously had agreed to appear to
back the passengers case i mean this is
unheard of
mi6 agents
are bound by a lifelong
official secrets hack they can go to
jail for revealing things
tony was the man
who
the british airways have claimed for 30
years that the briefer at the kuwaiti
embassy said it was safe to fly
so they flew
tony pace was this briefer
and he says the opposite he didn't tell
them it was safe to fly at all
he specifically said if you have a plane
going through mid path to midnight
it could get caught in the inver rocky
invasion which uh the plane was due to
land at 4am so faced with that warning
by the way from the briefer no airline
in its right mind would have flown
to a kuwait but british airways did
so here is pace breaking his silence
appearing in the press conference
alongside me
risking prosecution under the official
secrets act a very brave man
so here we are we have the press
conference there's me and pace and some
of the other human shields
um
lots of media which was great the
charming jon snow
who k interviewed me afterwards and ran
a good piece the bbc
um in a weird moment by the way when
tony pace
met jon snow tony said
i know you
and
the two of them were in a church choir
together at 12 years old
how weird is that
of all the things my mi6 contact jon
snow turning up the press conference in
a choir together at age 12.
anyway after the press conference and
after the interviews
to be honest i felt i mean obviously
adrenaline was pumping
to be honest i felt
overwhelmingly melancholy
and
i had to go and sit upstairs in a room
by myself for a couple of minutes
and i started to worry
whether i had raised the hopes of these
people
i mean there's a demand for an apology
there's a demand for the release of
documents
and i thought ah
have i raised the hopes of all of these
people beyond what's achievable
because well i can tell you for a start
they will never admit to the deniable
mission actually governments of all
stripes toys and
and labor like the ability to do this
black ops stuff so they're never going
to own up to that in
100 years
british airways will never own up to
what they did because they'd be facing
tremendous
financial claims there was i think a
chance that will get sandcastle released
under the 30-year rule and so it should
there's no earthly
national security reason now
for not telling people what happened the
suffering that these people suffered 30
years ago is that there's no reason
whatsoever
anyway i sat there thinking to myself ah
i really hope i haven't raised their
hopes too high
anyway then i went upstairs and all the
human shields had gathered in another
room we were put out on a lunch for them
in a union
and i walked in
and they all just came over to me one by
one
to hug me and say thank you for bringing
this to the public attention
and you know to be honest a lot of them
were crying and so was i
um and then i thought it's okay you know
and and since then by the way i've had
so many other people come out of the
woodwork and email me
people on the plane who i hadn't even
talked to before
saying the same thing so you know at
least i have the satisfaction after 30
years work of
of the
many more people knowing
what happened to the human shields of
the gulf war than did before so after
that i ceased being melancholy and felt
reasonably cheerful again
and um and in fact we've got now a major
podcast in preparation next year which
is going to be the story of the story
and um also i have a fantastic
script writer called matt orton who's
one of britain's top script writers and
a production company called house
productions working on a tv drama so
hopefully next year they'll be yet more
of a burst of publicity to further
embarrass the government in keeping the
sick pointless secret
i love it i mean the
podcasts that i've heard about similar
things is a very popular one called
passenger list which is
basically basically this story but
fictionalized that's unbelievably
popular you know dramatizing this will
will get attention on it and if it can
help bring these people some closure i
suppose it's efforts well spent
yeah i mean i'm not as a as a as a
pretty serious i think my friends would
tell you invested a reporter i'm not
i'm slightly uncomfortable with the
dramatization of anything
um but sex sells steven yeah yeah yeah i
know and and but but it's a way to bring
it to um
to close the public attention and it's
also a way to be frank to tell
some of the more horrific stories
i mean in in some of the more horrific
cases i have of course
not identified the people who were the
victims terrible things happened to
people while they were there um and so
when we dramatize it we can of course
show people the terrible things
while creating some kind of composite
character to represent so so and i guess
in that way it's helpful but yes you're
right look it's the modern world
and i'm i'm a little old-fashioned about
some of these things so you know
stephen davis ladies and gentlemen
operation trojan horse the most shocking
government cover-up of the last 30 years
will be linked in the show notes below
where else should people go is there
somewhere they can go to sort of keep up
to date with
developments around this
yes so obviously uh
the book is hardcover and it's available
on amazon the audiobook is out now but
you can also um
look at my site stephendaviswriter.com
stephendaviswriteraltogether.com and if
people are so one of the things this
experience taught me was a real interest
in misinformation and disinformation so
i've actually developed a course about
that i teach it at university in new
zealand university of otago i have a
tremendous interest in the use of
misinformation and disinformation and if
people want to read how misinformation
and disinformation was used in this
particular story
if you go to my site and you will find a
headline called misinformation and
disinformation
click on that and you will read quite
quite an interesting case history so
i'll be updating that site when i finish
my you know two weeks worth of
interviews with people like you
and um and and we'll be continually
pushing for
you know there's some suggestion of new
legal action by the passengers we'll be
we'll i'm going to keep going pushing
for the truth on this chris
steven thanks very much for today
brilliant no trouble
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe makes me very
happy indeed
peace
you